لقد خضت هذا التدريب
وأخبر مشاهدينا ما هو أسبوع الجحيم ،
لذا من المحتمل أن يكون أسبوع الجحيم أحد
أصعب البوتقات في تدريب الفقمة ،
وربما يكون
أحد أكبر الأشياء التي
تبني عقلية الفقمات التي تحدث عادة
في أي مكان من أربعة إلى ستة أسابيع في
الجزء الأول من تدريب الختم وهو
يحتضر مصممًا للتخلص من
أولئك الذين ليسوا ملتزمين
حقًا بك ، تعرف أن يصبحوا
ختمًا ويستمر لمدة أسبوع تقريبًا
، من الأحد إلى الجمعة ،
يحصل المرشحون على حوالي ثلاث إلى أربع
ساعات فقط  من النوم خلال ذلك الأسبوع
وخلال ذلك الوقت تكون مبللاً
بالرمال وتقوم بأنشطة بدنية مرهقة
طوال الأسبوع
ونفقد حوالي 80 بالمائة من الفصل
خلال أسبوع الجحيم ،
نعم
قرع الجرس
وأخبرنا لأنه مرهق للغاية
خاصة عندما  تمر
بأسبوع الجحيم درجة حرارة الماء وما إلى ذلك
فأنت في الماء كثيرًا ما
هو الاهتمام الطبي الذي أعنيه
هو أن الأشخاص على أهبة الاستعداد
للقفز وإعطائي
الخدمة اليومية إذا لزم الأمر ،
نعم تمامًا ، أعني أن فرق الختم
والمدربين في البراعم يقومون
بعمل رائع ، فهناك طاقم طبي بدوام كامل
مخصص لختم التدريب ، وهناك
طبيب في متناول اليد خلال أسبوع الجحيم في جميع
الأوقات يخضع المرشحون لفحوصات طبية
متعددة  مرات في اليوم
يتم فحصهم بحثًا عن انخفاض درجة حرارة الجسم ، حيث
يتم فحصهم بحثًا عن العدوى ،
لديهم حرفيًا فحص كامل للجسم
يحدث عدة مرات في اليوم ،
لذلك
يقوم البرنامج بعمل جيد جدًا من
الواضح مع أي نوع من التدريب عالي الخطورة
نحن نفعل دائمًا كل ما في
وسعنا للتخفيف من هذا الخطر ، ولكنه
توازن بين
كيفية التدريب على أعلى المستويات
الممكنة ، ومن الواضح أنه في تدريب الختم
أو تدريب الختم الأساسي ، نحاول
تشكيل هؤلاء المرشحين في أختام مستقبلية
يمكنها تحمل
بعض  من أصعب الضغوط الموجودة ،
لذا فهو دائمًا توازن ولكنني
أعلم أننا موجودون دائمًا بجانب
السلامة وأن المدربين
والطاقم الطبي يقومون بعمل رائع  عند القيام
بذلك تحدثت عن التوازن هنا
أه التأكد من حصولك
على أفضل
المجندين الذين يمكنهم القيام بالمهمة ولكن أيضًا
التأكد من أن السلامة هي أولاً وقبل كل شيء
ما هي تلك
المخاطر وأي نوع من التدريب عالي الخطورة
أقصد إذا  كانوا يدفعون الأفراد
إلى الحد من قدراتهم العقلية والعاطفية الجسدية
في بعض الأحيان ، أعني
أننا في الماء نشعر بالبرد ، أعني أنه
كثيرًا خلال أسبوع الجحيم
يتعرض الأفراد للجرح حتى
تتمكن من الحصول على ما يسمى التهاب النسيج الخلوي
العدوى تحت الجلد ،
يمكنك تناول مياه البحر حتى تعرف أنك
قد تكون
مصابًا بالتهاب رئوي منخفض المستوى مهما كان الأمر كما قلت على
الرغم من أن الأطباء والموظفين يقومون
بعمل جيد للغاية ، أعني أننا نفعل كل ما في
وسعنا للتخفيف من مخاطر ما  هؤلاء
الطلاب يمرون بذلك
بالتأكيد أه إنه عمل موازنة
ولهذا السبب لديهم الكثير من
الفحوصات الطبية وأنا أعلم أن البحار مولين
قد أكمل بالفعل قمح الجحيم لذلك
كان في الواقع بعد الجحيم  قبل أسبوع من
حدوث كل ما حدث ،
لن أتوقع أيًا من ذلك ،
لذا سيكون من المثير للاهتمام
معرفة ما يكتشفه الفاحصون الطبيون
ولكنك تعلم أثناء التدريب
عادةً إذا كان هناك حادث
يحدث فيه شيء ما ، فأنت تعلم أنه  لاحظت ذلك على
الفور ، لذا سيكون من المثير
للاهتمام معرفة ما ينتج عن ذلك ، فأنت تعلم
أنه قد أكمل التدريب بالفعل
قبل أن يحتاج هو وطالب آخر إلى
الذهاب إلى المستشفى